guys spiderman no way home has received
three golden tomatoes so i just wanted
to say a massive thank you on behalf of
everyone from sony and marvel the
critics the fans who have shown so much
love and respect and support for our
movies it means the world uh and you
know hopefully we can do it again and
again and again um but thank you thank
you thank you and we'll see you soon
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel all things mcu
and of course spider-man spider-man no
way home was a massive success
especially if you consider all of its
success during a pandemic right now if
we weren't in the middle of a pandemic
it might be the biggest movie of all
time but don't worry spider-man is going
to get another chance at the box office
in fact it's going to be getting three
more chances as marvel studios sony and
tom holland himself have all confirmed
that we are indeed going to be getting a
spider-man 4 5 and 6. tom holland is
going to be getting another trilogy in
fact tom holland just put out a recent
video thanking the fans for praising
spider-man no way home and helping them
get three golden tomatoes and he said
hopefully they can do it again and again
and again so more spider-man movies
coming what is in store for us though
with the future of spider-man
specifically who are the villains going
to be and will spider-man be joined by
any other heroes in his other films well
as it turns out we actually have a
pretty decent idea of who the villains
could be and another spider-man joining
tom hollands and i'll break it all down
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you can stay up to date on all mcu
news and of course spider-man news so
first and foremost thank you to kevin
feige and sony for right off the bat
right after spider-man no way home came
out they came out and said yes we are
indeed working on another spider-man
right now with tom holland kevin feige
said that the only reason he told us
that and confirmed it is because he
didn't want a lot of panic like what
happened last time there was the whole
little battle between sony and marvel
studios not too long ago where we didn't
really know if spider-man was going to
remain in the mcu or not or if sony were
going to take all of the rights back not
share anything with marvel and put tom
holland spider-man in their own sony
verse so thank you kevin feige for
confirming we are indeed going to be
getting a spider-man 4 and now a new
trilogy in the mcu with tom holland and
it looks like we kind of know what the
story is going to be and who the villain
is going to be for spider-man 4. now
this of course is thanks to the
spider-man no way home post credit scene
the first one not the doctor strange
trailer but the post credit scene with
venom we saw tom hardy's eddie brock and
of course venom and they were in the mcu
for a brief moment they kind of pulled
the fast one on us at the end of let
there be carnage venom went to the mcu
and we thought alright here we go this
is it tom hardy's eddie brock versus tom
holland spider-man but in the post
credit eddie brock and venom got taken
back to the sony universe but a piece of
the venom symbiote got left behind in
the mcu and here's where we pick up with
the story of spider-man 4. we know that
symbiotes are intelligent some more
intelligent than others in fact venom
the one that we know from the sony verse
has already admitted that back on his
home planet he's kind of a loser but we
know that they're intelligent
nonetheless and this piece of symbiote
that broke off from the venom symbiote
will become its own being but it's still
going to be a venom symbiote and this
venom symbiote just listened to a whole
conversation with eddie brock and this
bartender where the bartender explained
the avengers thanos and
spider-man in fact one of the last
things that eddie brock said was maybe i
should go to new york and talk to the
spider-man and it looks like that's
going to be this symbiote's plan go to
new york and find spider-man and from
here we'll probably get a story very
similar to spider-man 3 the sam raimi
spider-man 3 with tobey maguire for
those of you who don't like that movie
and i know a lot of people don't don't
worry this is marvel studios they've
handled everything exceptionally well so
far i'm sure the story is going to be
much different and things are going to
be handled much better in fact i'm
really excited for this because this
seems to be the comic accurate story of
the venom symbiote first bonding with
spider-man
peter parker how it's supposed to be
instead of like how sony did it where
the venom symbiote actually first bonded
with eddie brock but now in the mcu we
have a chance to start over the symbiote
will bond with tom holland spider-man
slash peter parker and of course from
there peter will have a little fun but
then he'll realize that the symbiote
isn't exactly a good thing he'll part
ways with it and then it'll go probably
to an eddie brock of the mcu maybe a
different character but we do know if
they are going for a comic accurate
story it should go to eddie brock next
and then of course from here we should
have a venom vs spider-man film now
there's always a chance that they could
bring in another villain as well but
based off of what has been set up so far
spider-man 4 should be a venom vs
spider-man film but what is next after
that well let's not forget what just
happened in hawkeye they introduced one
of spider-man's biggest villains kingpin
kingpin is now in the mcu and we would
assume that at some point in time he has
to run into peter parker spider-man you
can't put one of the biggest villains of
all time in the same universe as
spider-man and not expect them to meet
now we do have a long way to go until
then but this will probably be
spider-man 5 which means we probably
have between four to six years until we
see it maybe even longer unfortunately
but fortunately we are going to be
seeing kingpin in the mcu probably
several more times definitely in the
upcoming echo series and big spoilers
for the hawkeye series some of you may
be thinking but kingpin died in the very
last episode of hawkeye no he didn't we
know the rule if they don't actually
show the person dying that person is
probably still alive especially in the
marvel universe but what even more so
tells us that he is alive is that this
actually happens in the comics ekko
actually shoots kingpin in the face and
he goes blind in both eyes eventually he
does go on to get his sight back though
which is something that we can assume is
going to happen now spider-man no way
home brought matt murdock an aka
daredevil and he's supposed to be in the
echo series as well because if he's not
then that's a huge missed opportunity
because in the comics they're lovers
they fall in love with each other in
fact ekko falls in love with matt
murdock before she even knows that he's
daredevil but the two of them eventually
go on to know who each other are and
they both go on to fight against kingpin
so i can imagine that at some point in
time spider-man and daredevil will also
team up like they do in the comics a lot
so there is a possibility that say
spider-man 5 could be another somewhat
of a team-up movie for spider-man him
teaming up with daredevil to take down
the mighty kingpin now as far as a
villain for spider-man 6 we're thinking
way ahead now i know but trust me all
this stuff does get set up we could have
a true sinister six movie after all
there are a ton of villains still
remaining in the mcu that were not
addressed in spider-man no way home we
have vulture scorpion chameleon there
are quite a few villains in the mcu who
kind of got pushed under the rug a
little bit to have spider-man no way
home happen but we can assume that at
some point in time they'll probably come
back up especially since michael
keaton's vulture is in the morbius
trailer so spider-man 6 could be a true
sinister six film like where they
actually call them the sinister six now
kingpin could be in charge of that or
they could bring in their very own mcu
version of ozcorp and norman osborne now
this could be a little bit less likely
since in spider-man no way home norman
osborne said oscorp doesn't exist now it
doesn't mean that there's not another
norman osborne out there somewhere
trying to get it started or maybe the
company has called something else but
there is always the possibility and this
movie could also be a team-up film as
well since we did get a miles morales
easter egg and spider-man no way home
when jamie foxx finally figured out the
identity of spider-man he told andrew
garfield spider-man that he thought he
was going to be black and then he said
there's got to be a black spider-man out
there somewhere and he is right because
miles morales technically does exist in
the mcu in spider-man homecoming donald
glover aka the childish gambino played
prowler aaron davis the uncle of miles
morales and he even said in the scene
that he has a nephew that nephew of
course is miles morales which confirms
miles morales does exist in the mcu and
if i had to guess if this is going to be
tom holland's last trilogy as spider-man
they will probably set up miles morales
to be the new spider-man in the mcu by
the end of this new trilogy and if this
does happen that means miles will most
likely show up as his own version of
spider-man in the very last film and
then take over the spider-man mantle
which is something that i truly do hope
happens but let me know what you all
think is this a pretty good route for
the spider-man franchise to go down over
the next few years or would you like to
see something completely different let
me know your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and don't forget to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
news for live updates you can always
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you